Hàng 1 2, hăng Trung nghiên quan dụng bị yên sửa ra nè được lận quy đau, đánh dấu đời chữ tập lớn nhất kể từ khi cuộc chiến ở giải gà ra bùng phát tháng 10 năm 2018.
Nên cũng là giải gặp đủ tiền trong kế hoạt quy đau quy môn lớn, nhằm trình bị cho chế dịch chiếm đồng thành phố gà ra cdt.
Tuy nhiên, chuyên thống yên sửa ra nè, đời chữ tập lớn này đáng đối mặt với nhiều có khăn khi ngay cảnh ít quan dụng bị sẽ xà lý đường là miệng vụ.
Sao gần hai năm triệu sự liết tiếp và nhiều lần bị vọc tán ngũ.
Như quân nhanh xí mẹn giữa vụ vì lý do cả nhân mặc gái trình khiến tì lệ tháng ra tháp hưởng gạo dễ.
Các sĩ quan tất cả của lượng hộng về Israel, E.J. F quân thở nhật, ngay cả trong các đường bị chính quy quy môn đại đối và trong đổi đều đã bị thu hẹp.
Ngay khó khăn cho kế hoạt trên khai bổn xí đoàn tiền đánh khu đồ thiệt gà ra cdt.
Chết dính này được ước tình kéo ra, tự bốn đến năm tháng, tuy nhiên tiền trình sửa tán dân thường và trên khai lực lượng năng trậm hơn sỏ vệ kế hoạt.
Ngài ra nhiều trởi vì bận tỏ ra hoại nghi về khả năng đặt được khai mục tiêu thê chốt.
Đó là giả kí ủ bỗ mức tạm con tiền con sợ vâng đại chết và trên khám hoàn toàn các cứ điểm bỏ lại của lượng hà mắt.